our kids will love to choose what type
of movement they wanted to do but not
whether or not to do movement and you
know that's one of the ways I think
we've found ourselves to be like the
strictest parents like we give ours our
kids choice but it's within these very
clear sort of parameters and that
movement was one of them movement was
not whether or not they moved was not a
choice and how they wanted to move sky
is the limit we wanted to give our kids
the opportunity to try anything they
wanted because I'm really a true
believer that if you find a type of
movement that you like and enjoy and
that's fun for you then you will do it
and probably for your entire life